I don't know if you uh uh you you've
you've you've been following a lot of
the trials I'd imagine with January 6. a
couple of them so there were how many
have there been have there been three or
have we had more so far
I think three total trials I got
subpoenaed by the January 6th committee
that's a whole nother story that cost me
a fortune wow um but well so so we did a
segment on here and uh
I mentioned that for the people who just
walked in the front doors that were
opened by the cops how are you going to
charge them how are you going to convict
on trespassing when the cops open the
door and say come on in you know for
people who don't know about trespassing
you got to give a warning if you don't
have a sign in your property that says
no trespassing people can walk on your
property you can tell them to leave but
you got to give them a warning first if
you have a sign you don't need to give
them a warning because the sign the sign
is the warning basically so once the end
of the property you've got them on
trespassing the police can issue a
charge
I brought that up these you know Young
Turks for instance said I was stupid and
I was wrong and then what happens we
actually saw a guy get acquitted exactly
on those grounds yeah because the
Capitol building is a public free space
Americans can go in and out of there
foreigners can go in and out of there
literally almost any time of day it's
not trespassing there's certain areas
they can't go to and the cops are on
video opening the doors
yeah those guys need to be interrogated
so when we look at uh
I mean man when you look at what's going
on with what happened in Texas the the
the there's nothing that unifies this
country
right so this this thing happens and
what do we get what frustrates me the
most
I see posts from Democrat activists
saying Republicans are spineless and
they won't you know enact gun reform or
things like that they post there's a
meme going forward they're like ban the
AR-15 and I'm just sitting here like
none of these people have actually
offered up any real any real solutions
they're not interested in having a
conversation about any real solutions
they are Mindless drones saying ban the
AR-15 is it is literally meaningless no
it's like an assault rifle ban or you
know uh or or Shifting the other
conversation from oh that's an automatic
gun America doesn't allow the sale of
Automatic Farms and it doesn't it there
is no there is no it does with tax
stamps right pre-1984 or whatever right
no no but what I mean is okay it's like
let's let's approach it from this point
they've banned the AR-15 oh no and now
everyone's using the AR-10 they've
banned the AR-15 and my M1A or my scar
20s or like come on name a different gun
they exist they're coming out and
they're like they they use this rifle in
many instances with these with these
shootings it's an AR style Rifle right
and so they're saying ban this and I'm
like yo you're just not saying anything
I would like to see a poll of people
what they think AR stands for but
because I think a large percentage of
Americans think it means automatic rifle
or assault or assault rifle and it means
ArmaLite rifle which is the company that
created the thing yeah
but they'd have no idea what they're
talking about they don't even Google it
and so what do you get you get David
Hogg right he posts in April like I bet
if I sat down with with my critics we
would agree on things and I tweeted them
politely like hey man come on the show
you know we'd love to have you we'll
cover it they don't respond and so I
tried again he's got no obligation to
respond to me mind you I'm not you know
saying he has to but then he goes on
with Matt Walsh he goes on with
establishment personalities that are
just playing to the same audience
there's no real conversation happening
I look at that and I'm just like how
could anyone believe that the path
forward in this country is going to be
Unity
I just I just don't I can't I can't I
can't see it
anytime soon honey anytime soon not even
anytime late to be honest
until until we get ripped apart until
we've got English to bond us we've got
the almighty dollar I mean it was
basically a decentralized it's a
unification of states which are all
disunified you could say but unified
under the idea of the Constitution we
all follow the constitution for the most
part constitutional law presides in
every state those are the things that
hold us but our ideas never really were
supposed to be the same or anything like
that even religion you're allowed to
have your own religion but they're not
following the laws anymore California
for instance won't enforce immigration
law and it's actually granted them an
extra congressional seat and an extra
Electoral College vote because it's by
population not citizenry so when you
have States outright defying the union
and federal laws why would any other
state be like okay and now you know now
what do we get we get Oklahoma being
like okay we're gonna ban abortion out
right we don't care what this Supreme
Court says that's that's where we're
heading and I I I I I think it is a uh
it is the rule
not the exception that on the right
there's a conversation around policy
issues yeah and the Ben Shapiro will
yell debate me right that's the meme on
the left it's it's the exception they
don't debate and if they try to they
have no idea what they're talking about
well it's fake it that's why you're not
going to get a solution because they
have political epithets that they throw
out on any conversation gun control
abortion whatever immigration drugs
whatever you want to talk about but they
don't have actual Solutions and you're
right on the right they'll at least
debate them and then try to find an
answer like we do for the like we did
under Trump Administration for the
border for the opioid crisis for illegal
immigration and for things like you know
president Trump actually you know
reformed the criminal justice system
more than any president in modern
American history
and people don't know that you know
because he he a you know Republican
president was the one who did judicial
reform which is crazy it's a crazy
concept because it's not popular on the
right but I thought he was doing the
right thing and I thought it worked but
it gets covered up because no one wants
to talk about those things what do you
do
he did a lot of
it's getting technical but a lot of
alleviations of so when we sentence
people to for drug crimes and they get
sentenced um unequally because of skin
color or ethnic background it sort of
stacks up so you can eliminate those
rules and regulations you can give the
judges more flexibility to reduce those
types of sentences and he basically
undid the Biden 98 uh what's it called
crime bill you know he you you can't
Congress didn't veto it but you take out
a lot of the minimum mandatory sentence
requirements like grandmother gets found
with a gun under her bed that she
doesn't know is there and her nephew put
it there you're going to send her up the
creek for 10 years that's insane it's
insane but it ha it happens I've
defended people that that this happened
to and that's why you can't get any real
actual you know
true judicial reform without Congress
mandatory minimums in my opinion
stupidest things crazy stupidest thing I
I think you know our Judicial System
needs to be human
it's it's supposed to be judges are
supposed to interpret the law
so you're supposed to have like Grandma
how'd you come across that snub nose and
should be like I don't know it's not
mine and they're like okay well 10 years
well no it should it should it should be
like we're seizing it if you don't know
where it came from and it's not yours
then it's ours now right don't let it
happen again nobody got hurt did the
mandatory minimums come up because
judges were giving people they knew like
low sentences
yeah well they can't unless you unless
you fix the law or unless you give the
judges uh the ability to use this thing
called a safety valve exception in
federal court and they didn't have a lot
of those tools but you also have to
appoint judges who are going to do that
who are going to see the way things that
that Tim just said exercise judicial
discretion and that was a big part of
the the candidates of you know
candidates the appointees that Trump put
into the federal Judiciary is people who
exercise discretion on the criminal side
I can't speak for federal government but
I know that in Illinois the mandatory
minimums on say drug sentencing or or
burglary sentencing was to deter crime
so the idea was that a criminal would
find out that the law was passed no they
don't they don't know they don't care
there's no they know they go to jail if
they get caught so you end up with crazy
stories I remember one story was about a
teenager who uh his neighbors went out
of town
the neighbors asked this kid their next
door neighbors to keep an eye on the
house the kid knowing they weren't there
broke in the back door using the keys
because he had the keys and he stole a
beer
cops driving by saw someone was in there
knowing the people were out of town went
in arrested them and then they were like
they said about this kid like okay we
don't think he should be charged with
anything severe maybe trespassing and
the D.A was like no no no there's a
there's a mandatory minimum for burglary
he went in the property he took
something he burglarized the property
and so apparently like it was a it was
done it was four years and the the judge
was like I don't want to do this but
it's out of my hands it's statutory and
then the prisons were like there is no
way we are taking a kid who took a beer
to come here and it was this huge legal
battle I don't exactly remember what
happened but this is a story I heard I
think it was like 18 years ago now
talking about it in Illinois that's the
problem with these things anyone can
look at that and be like kid don't take
beer from your neighbors and the
neighbors would have been like oh yeah
that's Johnny like okay well we're fine
with him taking a couple bucks courts
didn't care they didn't see it that way
those things are dumb so that was good
the the the crime of Reform stuff that
Trump had done yeah but the problem is
over correction at least in the law
enforcement area in the Judiciary right
drugs become a problem they overcorrect
20-year minimum mandatory sentences for
if you're caught with this amount of
this or this amount of that that's a lot
of time that most people like Tim said
don't know about it's an over correction
same thing with
um gun control right it it'll get I
think it's going to get to a point where
there'll be an over correction instead
of the right correction because it'll be
political and not the one that people
actually want and it's going to get
messy what do you think would be like
the right correction or um well gun
control for gun control I mean look I'm
a big two-way guy I'm all for it but I
think
while I agree that we have background
checks I think our background check
system isn't good it's run by the
government and it's not done the way it
needs to be done I mean that is like the
FBI runs it or ATF or whatever right but
there can be a better system of
screening take another day or two and
build a better algorithm to screen out
people with prior activities prior hits
prior contacts with law enforcement
mental illness issues things like that
people keep saying oh we have background
checks well you can have background
checks if they suck then what's the
point but on step one do they suck I
mean the first time I went to buy guns
it took I was on a I was on the
mandatory weight I was delayed well
that's that's government I mean sure
that it's putting you on a wait list for
the government to give you a response
that's kind of standard Library I think
there's there's a lot of good intentions
in the background check system yeah I
think reforming it would give you the
exact same results really yeah it's
government man you know there's there's
some things I'm okay with when it comes
to government but I'm like if it's not
working now what can we do to fix it
well I certainly think it's worth
looking at trying to fix for sure
I just think it will devolve you'll
start you'll start off really great and
then after a little while I'll start to
break down but you know I will say this
I'm I'm in favor I I would I would
actually agree I'll I'll kind of you
know simmer down a little bit I think
one of the problems we have with
government is that we create a program
and walk away from it and then what
happens is it starts to fester and rot
if we came back every couple of years
and said let's start it over and
reassess we could actually adapt and if
we're looking at our background checks
through the through the Knicks when you
buy a gun and we're like how is it not
working what can we do to make it work
better and then we just adapt and move
what we're already doing I think we
could maybe we could maybe improve it
for sure let me ask you this so what do
you think the the background checks that
we have right now are missing
data hard data about contacts with law
enforcement and individuals who've had
run-ins with Mental Hospitals and mental
health issues that's one of the biggest
you know things and now that with the
Advent of social media
they're not we're not capturing all the
flags of these guys putting on you know
you can put up whatever you want on
social media well not on Twitter but on
truth you can and you can say whatever
you want but if you're out there you
know screaming with guns on social media
about attacking someone that's that's
got to be flagged somehow and that that
algorithm has to be better to capture
that data to give it to the government
to put in that database to screen off of
because every one of these serial uh you
know massacres they all have one
unifying
um connection and that is a mental
health issue of some sort but what sort
of what sort of contact with law
enforcement would you flag as being
justified to remove somebody's
constitutional rights yeah that's a
great question so not just any contact
but if you had contact and the person
was appeared mentally ill then you had
them referred for mental health referral
and balance check then yeah then that
should be when they go to buy a gun I'm
not saying they should be denied I'm
saying that information should be in the
system so someone can go look at it and
say okay should we give this person a
gun let's go check on him let's go pull
all his social media let's go see what
he's been saying that's all I'm not
saying you can't get it but it needs to
be better so it's like a type of red
flag law it's kind of what yeah I don't
I don't think it works man I don't know
look it's not every so you'd have to
quantify mental illnesses yeah it's not
just any mental illness and then you've
got the issue of you're getting
dangerously close to free speech people
can post things and then what a
background check gives arbitrary
authority to some agency that's unseen
to be like we just think this guy's no
good I I already think it was bad that
when I went to buy a weapon so I we get
we get death threats I mean it's been it
you know we have we have these issues I
want to take care of myself protect
myself I go to the gun store and they're
like fill out the forms they said you're
delayed we'll let you know
why I I am a law-abiding citizen I have
no history of mental illness there's
nothing on my record
but I get delayed now imagine they used
to say they start using people's speech
against them all of a sudden now people
are having their constitutional rights
curtailed but not even their
constitutional rights their god-given
rights to defend themselves from some of
these crazy people from lunatics or just
to keep in bear arms I mean regardless
you have a you know you have a right
regardless of government my opinion to
do it it gets dangerous when
already there is I think it's the FBI
that does it that does the the national
instant check system or whatever it's
called it's already bad enough they
could deny you and you don't know why it
happened to James O'Keefe he got put on
the list remember this they just
arbitrarily put him on the list and he
couldn't buy a weapon to file a lawsuit
fortunately he has the support to
actually do that
this is why I don't I don't know if
there is actually a solution outside of
cultural issues because we can talk
about all of these things we can we can
do but then you take a look at this dude
in Texas and and he first of all how did
he afford this the thousands I mean
eight thousand dollars in Weaponry
whatever
the money should have been a barrier but
it wasn't then he passes the background
checks
what what could have been done the left
says ban the AR-15 so then he buys an AK
that's not gonna work that you're not
you're not saying anything they say do
background checks he passed a background
check do better background checks and
then what regular people all of a sudden
can't defend themselves look the end
result of what the Democratic position
is I should I shouldn't say the left I
apologize for that because left is like
guns I always got to correct myself they
do they're big on guns the end result is
just ban all guns that is the only thing
and then even that won't work because 3D
printed guns exist and you can make a
gun out of a 3D printed material you
don't need much metal other than the
firing pin a thumbtack or something well
even even in addition to that I mean we
already have more guns in this country
than we have people you think all those
people are going to get rid of the guns
because you pass a law now they're going
to lose them in boating I mean you think
everybody with a bump stock turned it in
because the government said nope can't
have it hey and that was Trump and there
was one jurisdiction where they had they
they had a thing where you could return
I don't know if it was a buyback or not
they wanted you to return in your Bump
stocks and the uh out of the entire city
they got seven wow all right what do you
think it happened to all the other ones
I heard somebody on Twitter and they
said you know we need we need gun
buybacks we need we need BuyBacks who's
gonna buy them the government
and they said they said no no they were
like five thousand dollars per gun and I
was like dude do you I'll go to the gun
store and buy a gun for a couple hundred
bucks and then bring it in for five
grand are you nuts I guess I guess their
idea is like yeah then the government
basically buys every gun from every gun
store and there's no guns no then people
start 3D printing them and turning them
in for five grand hey it's ten bucks in
plastic and now I got you know it
doesn't work man but that's the thing
they're already there so I was gonna do
is create a black market yeah and then
if somebody wants to find a gun they're
gonna find a gun if somebody wants to
kill they're going to find a way to kill
whatever video you gotta start
addressing the cultural the cultural
aspects of this and people's behavior
what's triggering people now that these
young kids want to start slaughtering
their their classmates when this it
hasn't been a precedent in the United
States until what 1999 we've had guns in
the schools and guns in kids hands since
since the 1800s this is a very recent
problem I'm looking at the
pharmaceutical industry and kids on
Klonopin when they're 12 or 14.
Wellbutrin Prozac yeah Adderall Adderall
my gosh Adderall it's an amphetamine and
and then the kids don't know have
emotions they never cried it out when
they were 13 because they couldn't
didn't feel the tear they didn't feel it
and now they're they're lashing out like
wild mindless or emotionless rather
giving kids amphetamines or ssris just
all of this stuff that kids are being
pumped full of
and and I also got to say social media
yeah we we talk about the media aspect
of this how these these shooters think
they're going to get notoriety but it's
also
people I I don't I don't know much about
maybe you guys saw this where people on
Discord were apparently egging this guy
on
you see this stuff you know I've seen
posts before people like you know do it
you're a loser you won't do it and they
try and egg them on
if that's not helpful it feels like it's
so entrenched like I'm like okay you
could homeschool your kids arm the
teachers and take the kids off of
psychoactive Pharmaceuticals but like
that's like all right Titanic you're
about to hit the iceberg turn left like
it sounds like first of all how in the
hell are you gonna do all that the
pharmaceutical industry if it feels like
from my perspective that it's so
entrenched in our in our existence at
this point I don't know how many billion
dollar industry it is and like the way
Pfizer just ran the coveted response
seemingly like they were in charge
somehow Corporation was in charge I I
don't know how to get Pharmaceuticals
out of 12 year olds hands exactly
but I mean it's a scary reality man you
gotta educate the parents but you know
I'd be willing to bet that if you start
talking about the pharmaceutical role
and what's been happening in this
country the dramatic Spike I'd be
willing to bet this Maybe I'm Wrong
there is going to be a visible
correlation between the increase in
medicating children and the increase in
violent outbursts General violence and
maybe mass shootings or things like this
General violence because I think the
drugs are messing kids up but if you
start talking about that you know that
big Pharma is funding all of these
networks they're not going to say it you
know have you ever seen that Meme where
it's like you know local news brought to
you by Pfizer it's like CNN brought to
you by Pfizer and ABC and all that stuff
yeah yeah you're not going to be on one
of these big networks bad mouthing the
pharmaceutical companies
odd because it is I mean it's got to be
the pharmaceutical it's got to be the
drugs it's got to be psychoactive drugs
and the 14 15 year old kids what else I
mean it's driving them insane I don't
know if it has to be I think it plays a
role I think social media plays a huge
role man yeah I think I think it's a
combination of factors but what what
frustrates me the most is that for many
people on the left their only response
is to want to confiscate guns
liberals liberals excuse me liberals is
to to uh to curtail the civil rights to
curtail the constitutional rights of
people who committed no crime at all we
have some so if we're looking at a scale
of things that are reasonable versus not
reasonable it seems that would be very
reasonable to just say why don't we lock
down our schools and have a single point
of entry single point of exit and
security guard that's something very
easy that we could do that's something
that would be incredibly cost effective
given how much money we spend on other
things like 40 million dollars to
Ukraine and every single time we we
propose a Common Sense solution you know
they dig their heels into the ground and
they say no their only answer is gun
control
yeah yeah and and gun control it's just
doesn't do anything I'm really concerned
about I think you mentioned red flag
laws earlier and like if someone has a
medical marijuana card and the
government has it scheduled as a
narcotic for some freaking reason yeah
you're you're out if if you get this is
this is this is really messed up if you
have a medical marijuana card you can't
you can't get a gun as a currently stamp
one yeah yeah and I remember I was in
California and I was I was skating in
Venice and there are these guys that
stand outside of these shops and they're
like yo yo we card we card we card and
I'm skating and the dude goes bro bro
come here come here and I was like I
stop what up because you got your weed
card yet and then I was like I was like
what do I need a weed card for and he's
like oh medical marijuana dude he's like
you got to get medical marijuana man and
then I was like
I don't need it and he goes oh no you
got something we're gonna talk to the
doctor man you don't know until you talk
to the doctor and then I was like I'm
healthy and I got nothing wrong with me
he goes you skateboard your feet hurt
and I was like I mean sometimes like oh
dude you need weed you gotta come and
talk to the doctor five bucks
I got my medical card in San Francisco
and they're like so what's the problem I
was like I'm stressed he's like what's
what's stressing you out is like the
Federal Reserve has a monopoly on her
monitor system and the guy was like
signed he just gave it to me but but now
you can't get a gun well not in
California I don't know maybe not
California I don't know my license
anymore but I don't know how those laws
work yeah I don't know how absolute it
is it might be like you're a current
user those cards can disqualify you yeah
if you have a card you see what they do
yeah wow and how many how many people
were like oh yeah I'll get a car it's
five bucks I might not use it and boom
now it's like you got to put that in the
form and they're gonna deny you the
background check form you fill out asks
you if you've used drugs so what but not
alcohol doesn't mention alcohol or does
it mention Pharmaceuticals either well
well hold on it does mention call the
good news is there is an exemption okay
if you're Hunter Buddies
you just got to toss your legally
purchased firearm into a dumpster
afterwards yeah so for those that don't
know he lied on his form and then he
what his wife did it or something she
threw it in a garbage can uh dumpster
behind the school yes yeah we had school
so insanely illegal oh man and then Joe
Biden comes out and he's like I care
about this like no you don't arrest your
kid and then we'll talk I don't know Joe
Biden while they while this was going
down he was on another Network giving uh
a speech or something unrelated to this
just just flip the rolls if there was a
school shooting Massacre and Donald
Trump didn't stop everything he was
doing rightly so and shift to the school
shooting stop whatever event he was at
but Joe Biden like you said he doesn't
care he was he was out reading some
teleprompter somewhere while 20 20
children just got murdered if he really
cared you stop and you get your ass down
to Texas and you say I'm here I care he
didn't go to Waukesha he didn't go oh
I'm busy and then what does he do he
comes out and he's like or a deer we're
in cuff floor it's like dude are you
hunting deer with handguns what do you
what do you mean by this there's he's
not he's I'm sorry they're not saying
anything they're not saying this I I I I
I genuinely want the violence to stop I
want I want to solve this okay and so I
am not a gun expert but I know a little
bit more than the average person and I
own several and so having been to the
range having talked with instructors
haven't been giving and given
instruction Having learned about the
laws and having to deal with it myself
I'm like hmm interesting and then every
single liberal that I talk to about this
will say something that makes no sense
like there was that famous news video
that news I think it was CNN I'm not
sure they said fully semi-automatic not
a thing it doesn't yeah they think
silencers are they've never actually
heard he's watched a movie though
they've watched a movie and they think
that they think these things and then
it's just fascinating when I when they
say ban the AR-15 and I'm like
you're not saying anything how do we I
don't know how to solve this man if if
you can't actually engage I made a tweet
about it I said with all of the death
and destruction it's time to do the only
logical thing and Implement gun policy
based on the opinions of people who've
never handled or researched guns that's
right
the Democratic party yeah there you go
all right so I'm glad we solved the
two-way issue tonight yeah
so I just I'm at the point now when they
come out with these emotional attacks or
whatever I'm just like I literally don't
care that you're not going to come to me
and I'm I'm tired of playing this and
I'm not going to Pander to anybody I'm
not going to be you know you know what's
really funny is every single time
everyone addresses a school shooter they
go deep into the psychopath it's
deranged person we get it like Ted Cruz
is talking to a journalist and he's like
this this psychotic this psychopath and
I'm like that's what everybody does
and it's predictable they do this but we
all know no one is going to no one in
good faith is going to be like oh Ted
Cruz didn't think the person was crazy
we know these people are crazy we all
get that but it's gonna be tough to find
a solution when one party has no vested
interest or no real interest in actually
resolving the issue they just want gun
control so we it's hard to have an
honest conversation they're never going
to come to the table and accept the fact
or publicize the the fact that 89 of all
gun deaths in the United States are due
to gang violence and suicides yeah you
know school shootings are an incredibly
rare event
um gun deaths in general outside of
suicides and gang violence are an
incredibly rare event but but given how
the media covers it you think that we
have a crisis of mass proportions in the
united in the United States even if you
look at it on a per capita basis you
know deaths per 100
000 uh the United States doesn't even
rank in the top ten for for uh mass
shootings yeah and and it's mostly with
handguns most mass shootings are
handguns and we never talk about Chicago
and this is another it's like a cliched
response you'll get from a lot of a lot
of people especially on the right
but I get it it's it you know look kids
dying is is a shock to the system that's
I understand why we talk about that for
sure
but we do have mass shootings all the
time in Chicago in Baltimore in Detroit
in these cities no one seems to care
about them so I guess black lives don't
really matter to them well did you see
that video where the uh the guy walks up
to the hospital where everyone's got the
signs and he says do black lives matter
and like yes and he's like what about
the babies that are being aboard he's
like yeah I didn't think so so I
certainly think when they when they call
Candace Owens a white supremacist system
these are not serious people when Larry
Elder is the black face of white
supremacy these are not serious people
yo I would love to solve these problems
and move this country forward but it's
it's seemingly impossible now I I can
I'll fully recognize there are people on
the right who are just as bad oh yeah
but the thought leaders within the right
are having the conversations people like
I'll just shut up Ben Shapiro's got one
of the biggest podcasts in the world he
is a conservative he is a very
mainstream traditional conservative
Orthodox Jew and he is all about having
conversations with people why not have
those conversations some people do
but when we try and invite prominent
people on the left they won't do it they
won't have these conversations and when
I try to engage with them they don't
have the answers they don't have any
proposals that make sense there's
something about the arrogance that we we
see with the establishment Democrats and
don't get me wrong the uniparty
Republicans along with them
where there's almost no interest in
getting anything done thanks for
checking out this segment from the
timcast IRL podcast but if you want to
check out the full show live tune in
Monday through Friday at 8 pm and if you
want more special access content head
over to timcast.com and become a member
your membership helps sustain this
company keep our journalists employed
makes this show happen and you will get
access to exclusive members only
segments of the timcast IRL podcast and
there's a massive library to check out
so again go to timcast.com or tune in
Monday through Friday at 8pm and we'll
see you all there